so you want to get a degree in
mathematics hopefully that means you
have an appreciation of the beauty of
mathematics and an interest in it beyond
it being a tool to potentially make
money if not then you are probably going
to have a miserable few years ahead
University mathematics is difficult if
you are still in the mindset of saying
that you don't care about ideas if you
can't see their application in your day
to day life then you will find many
higher math topics hard to grasp because
University maths becomes very abstract
I'm a recent graduate of mathematics as
well as physics and this was my
experience in first year math I was
introduced straightaway to matrix
algebra and the connection between
matrices and linear systems of equations
this was new for me but more familiar
ideas were also expanded such as first
order differential equations evaluating
limits of functions interpreting partial
derivatives vectors and 3d series and
sequences integration involving
trigonometry and probability another new
idea that became fundamental was
eigenvalues and eigenvectors they are a
way to scale vectors using
characteristics of the system in
second-year multivariable calculus and
differential equations get a lot more
attention a link is made between linear
algebra and solving differential
equations you'll find that you need to
think more deeply about ideas and their
connection to other branches of math
you'll be allowed to take notes with you
into the
but this won't help you the spooky
reality is that you actually need to
have prepared deeper than just recording
a recipe of steps to take in second year
I encountered the most abstract course I
took that was a real analysis where you
desperately try to prove things that
seem obvious group theory and the study
of symmetry was also abstract because
the symmetrical objects you're
describing are often not physical ones
my third and final year of math study
included complex analysis just like the
real version but using the imaginary
numbers interestingly you can take
complicated integrals convert them to
imaginary numbers to solve it in a more
simple way and then convert the answer
back into something real the third
installment of differential equations
was more difficult than the last two and
the study of dynamical systems turned
out to be a really interesting look at
chaos as well as predicting where
systems become stable I was lucky enough
to take a course on the history of
mathematics including ancient teachings
done through poetry and looking at
Babylonian tablets the courses I took
were only a subset of what's possible
for people interested in computer
science you can take discrete math or
cryptography and coding theory and I
haven't even mentioned statistics the
main software I used for math was
MATLAB and maple which can make some
pretty nice plots a mathematics degree
gives you the ability to work in any
field with complex systems that need to
be understood or with any job that wants
to make sense
of data math skills can be used as
broadly as you want by combining it with
any other interest whilst studying maths
you realize how obscure some of what
you're learning is when you speak to
friends from other subjects you can
usually understand somewhat what they
are talking about but math ideas
sometimes very hard to explain to people
who have not come down the same path to
understand math yourself is hard but
helping others to appreciate it too is
the real challenge